[Applaudissements]
il était un peu fatigué hier il a fait
ça toute mise en plis elle est de retour
il est tout neuf tout beau romaine
patins avis qu'au regard des pommes de
terre passe comment ça va bébé il a très
très bien les ya des nouveautés soir ya
des nouveaux délires ce soir on débrief
le ballon d'or déjà c'est normal et on a
suivi la guerre qui fait rage dans les
loges de tpm pc ça notre nouveau rendez
vous mais comme chaque jour on commence
avec l'actualité du monde des médias
c'est notre tour du paf gens nus que
continue de préparer la cigale il y aura
du breakdance apparemment on prend des
nouvelles de charles au fond je parle
très vite parce que sinon on va pas y
arriver
hélas en avance rapidement rejoint voilà
j'ai fait mon maximum
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire thierry henry j il avait calé
pour julien lepers allons rester
tranquilles 58 ans qui est ce que
voulait le faire passer à autre chose
avant passe à autre chose vous avez là
c'est quand même sympa pour moi sourit
merci alors on est à un bon retour
[Rires]